you're way too complicated frustrating
and slow goodnight Apple watch there's
always tomorrow or version two
[Music]
waaah sound never gets any less annoying
how'd you sleep buddy
sadly the Apple watch still doesn't have
sleep tracking oh wait that's the
original Apple watch almost two years
and no design change here browser you
can have that one it's actually faster
with the new watch OS come on browser I
want to squeeze in a run before my new
meeting I really still like this thing
first and foremost as a watch with a
lowercase W alright let's give this new
GPS feature a shot 1 mile no phone
oh wait that's dental floss these air
pods are much easier than pairing my old
beats and there we go the best running
song of all time Britney Spears baby one
more time of course still such a bummer
that there's no cellular chip in here
though I'd still really rather run with
my phone right now so I can stream music
and keep in touch with my family
alright these air pods stay in pretty
well the screen really is way brighter
much easier seeing Sun all right
half a mile left I feel the battery
draining they crammed a bigger battery
in this chunky thing but you won't
notice if you use the GPS need water
take that chip cards
[Music]
where's the damn subway at least the
some processor and software are much
faster so what do you think should we
get him for the conference I think as
few humans wait hold on I'm getting an
alert to breathe let's take a second to
breathe together what you don't go
swimming in the middle of the day all
right
cool swim it is this pool is about 18 to
19 yards and start swimming stay hungry
oh wow
six laps I'm pretty much Michael selves
and now we need to eject the water by
rotating this and boom ejected that's
awesome well these are gross
here goes nothing maash what bowling
doesn't count as a workout I deserve
these all of these what a day Apple
watch you've turned into a great fitness
companion and thank goodness you're
faster but you're still too thick and
need more battery that's why some might
prefer this Fitbit charge for half the
price
good night Apple watch there's always
tomorrow
or Version three